[Musique]
les policiers perquisitionnent chez le
suspect et ils vont faire une découverte
incroyable l'homme possède chez lui un
véritable arsenal il avait une
multistement à Paris là on est plus dans
la collection simple on est en présence
d'un arsenal enfin c'est plus de la
collection vous voyez je dirais
la collectionneur du dimanche
17 mai 2005 le bois de pipele dans la
petite commune de Sucy-en-Brie en
banlieue parisienne
en ce début d'après-midi un retraité
fait sa balade habituelle
mais après quelques minutes de marche à
une centaine de mètres de l'entrée du
bois le promeneur découvre un corps
allongé par terre
[Musique]
il prévient immédiatement la police
c'est la brigade criminelle du quai des
Orfèvres à Paris qui est chargé de la
faire
les policiers se rendent immédiatement
sur place
la police intervient rapidement
ils font des constatations
les enquêteurs vont découvrir sur place
que l'homme a été assassiné son corps
vit dans une mare de sang son crâne
présente plusieurs impacts de base
la victime est un homme de type européen
d'une quarantaine d'années il est de
taille moyenne il a le crâne rasé et ne
porte pas de barbe
comme le veut la procédure la police
passe la scène de crimes au peigne fin
et les policiers retrouvent près du
corps une cigarette à moitié consumée
à qui appartient le mégot à la victime
ou à l'assassin
la cigarette est prélevée et envoyée au
laboratoire de la police scientifique
pour une recherche ADN
autour du corps les policiers ne
trouvent ni l'arme du crime ni aucune
trace de lutte
mais en y regardant de plus près ils
sont attirés par des tranches taches
blanchâtres sur les feuilles d'un
arbuste
les policiers découvrent des traces de
cocaïne sur des feuilles et parpillées
autour du corps la victime était elle
mêlée à un trafic de stupéfiants
les policiers fouillent dans ses poches
et découvrent sa carte d'identité
l'homme s'appelle Christophe belle il a
40 ans il est originaire d'Angers et il
réside à Courbevoie en banlieue
parisienne
immédiatement les policiers décident de
se rendre à son domicile situé à 25 km
de là
la victime habite dans cette résidence
c'est la compagne de Christophe Bell qui
leur ouvre la porte j'entends frapper à
ma porte et
là on me dit bonjour madame brigade
criminel
je sais qu'il est arrivé quelque chose
de grave dès que je les vois ma porte
mais pas 30 secondes je pense à ce
qu'ils allaient m'annoncer
et là on me dit voilà on a retrouvé
votre concubin
assassiné dans un bois à Sucy-en-Brie
donc le choc je suis prise de froid je
comprends plus trop bien ce qui m'arrive
je suis en bring commune dont j'ai
jamais entendu parler
je comprends pas je comprends pas
c'était impossible Christophe ne pensait
qu'à son travail n'avait pas de souci
particulier comment voulez-vous qu'on
puisse penser qu'il s'est fait
assassiner immédiatement sandrine est
interrogée et elle est surprise par
l'attitude des policiers
on commence à me faire une perquisition
chez moi je comprends pas trop bien non
plus pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on cherche
les enquêteurs expliquent à Sandrine ce
qu'il cherche de la drogue et il pose
des questions surprenantes son compagnon
avait-il l'habitude de prendre ou de
vendre de la cocaïne
on m'a posé la question à plusieurs
reprises à ce que vous êtes
consommateurs de cocaïne est-ce que vous
êtes revendeur etc moi je comprends pas
pourquoi on me parle de drogue alors que
jamais jamais on a consommé quel que
soit peu importe la drogue on a jamais
consommé
[Musique]
il faut savoir qu'une enquête de la
brioche criminelle c'est rien n'est
laissé au hasard
ils prennent tous les éléments et c'est
vrai quand on trouve un type à 3h du
matin dans un bois avec de la drogue
autour du cadavre on peut effectivement
imaginer que ce meurtre est un règlement
de compte entre dealer où une
transaction qui se qui serait mal passée
la piste d'un crime crapuleux liée au
trafic de drogue et la seule dont
dispose les policiers
pourtant lorsqu'ils vont s'intéresser de
plus près à la personnalité de la
victime les enquêteurs vont très vite
s'apercevoir que cette piste ne tient
pas
[Musique]
la vie de Christophe belle et celle d'un
homme sans histoire
il est pâtissier et passe l'essentiel de
son temps dans la boulangerie pâtisserie
qu'il possède dans le Marais dans le
centre de Paris
Christophe belle mène une vie de moine
entre guillemets et de travail c'est un
type qui se lève de par sa profession de
pâtissier à deux heures du matin tous
les jours et il prend sa moto l'ours se
rendre sa pâtisserie qui se trouve rue
Vieille-du-Temple à l'enseigne l'avion
des Lys je pense qu'il avait deux
univers différents mais seulement deux
univers celui de la boutique
dans lequel travailler 12 heures par
jour et puis son univers familial c'est
quelqu'un qui est très doué qui va
travailler de ses mains c'est pas un
grand intellectuel c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a fait de très longues études c'est
quelqu'un qui est doué dans sa
spécialité et qui va au fil du temps
essayer de développer des activités
professionnelles en rapport avec ce
qu'il aime alors qui pouvait bien en
vouloir à ce pâtissier à la vie bien
rangée comme le confirme la déposition
de sa compagne et Sandrine la vie de
Christophe est très éloignée de celle
d'un trafiquant de cocaïne ou même de
celle d'un simple consommateur et les
enquêteurs qui vont vraiment chercher
dans son histoire dans ses relations etc
dans les répertoires téléphoniques il
rencontrait etc vont rapidement
s'apercevoir qu'il n'a strictement aucun
lien avec quelques trafics de produits
stupéfiant que ce soit l'autopsie va
révéler que il n'est pas consommateur de
stupéfiant
et l'enquête de personnalité va révéler
qu'il a une vie linéaire que c'est un
type qui ne qui n'a pas de problème mais
si le crime n'est pas lié à la drogue
comment expliquer alors la présence de
cocaïne près du corps
la drogue a peut-être été déposée
volontairement par le tueur pour lancer
les policiers sur une fausse piste
alors pour mieux comprendre ce qui a pu
se passer cette nuit là ils vont tenter
de reconstituer les dernières heures de
Christophe Bel
[Musique]
Sandrine explique aux enquêteurs que ce
17 mai 2005 au matin Christophe s'est
levé plutôt que d'ordinaire
il me dit je dois me lever plus tôt
demain parce qu'il manque
des employés entre autres des apprentis
qui sont absent pour passer leur examen
Christophe Bell quitte donc son domicile
vers 3h du matin
mais contrairement à son habitude il ne
prend pas la direction du centre de
Paris pour rejoindre sa pâtisserie au
contraire il se dirige vers Sucy-en-Brie
dans la banlieue est de la capitale
pourquoi à ce stade de l'enquête on
l'ignore en revanche les policiers ont
déterminé qu'il fallait une demi-heure
environ pour rejoindre en moto le bois
du pipel il est donc 3h30 lorsque
Christophe belle se gare à l'entrée de
la forêt après avoir marché une centaine
de mètres il allume la cigarette que
l'on retrouvera près de son corps l'ADN
retrouvé sur le mégot correspond au sien
quelques secondes plus tard il aurait
été exécuté par un tireur qui se tenait
derrière lui
mais une question se pose rapidement
chez les enquêteurs et chez les proches
de Christophe belle je me suis demandé
de ce que pouvait faire mon frère dans
un bois dans la région parisienne
alors qu'il le seul trajet qui
connaissait c'était celui entre
Courbevoie et le marin le pâtissier
a-t-il fait une mauvaise rencontre ou au
contraire avait-il convenu d'un
rendez-vous
pour tenter de répondre à toutes ces
questions les enquêteurs vont interroger
l’entourage de Christophe belle et ils
vont rapidement se rendre compte que cet
homme sans histoire n'avait pas que des
amis
[Musique]
Sandrine me conduit apprend rapidement
aux policiers que depuis plusieurs mois
son compagnon Christophe belle avait un
ennemi un certain Frédéric Feugrais lui
aussi pâtissier
depuis plusieurs mois les deux hommes
avaient un différent commercial suite à
un procès au tribunal de commerce de
Nanterre ce dénommé secret accusé
Christophe d'avoir fait un faux
témoignage contre l'une de ses amis et
depuis leur relation s'était sévèrement
en venimée quelques mois avant son décès
il y a eu les pneus de sa moto et
également de notre voiture qui ont été
crevées à plusieurs reprises dans notre
parking je crois également qu'il y a eu
la réserve de la boutique qui a été
retournée
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque Christophe
pensait que c'était justement ce fameux
pâtissier avec qui il était en litige
on va dire par vengeance qui venait lui
crever ses pneus voilà et les Mons
troublant Frédéric Feugrais habite
justement à Sucy-en-Brie dans un
pavillon situé à seulement 150 mètres du
bois ou Christophe belle a été assassiné
les policiers de la brigade criminelle
pensent tenir enfin une piste solide
feugré et placés en garde à vue et il
reconnaît qu'il avait indifférent il
avoue même avoir laissé à Christophe un
message téléphonique très agressif
avez-vous fait des menaces sur ce
message
assurément je n'ai pas été sympa j'étais
énervé j'ai même dû lui dire qu'il
fallait concevoir un truc comme ça je
n'ai pas dit qu'on allait se battre mais
au fur et à mesure de la garde à vue les
policiers vont déchanter le secret en
question un alibi en béton il est
et son téléphone le démontre il est à
l'autre bout de Paris ou peut-être même
en province au moment du crime autre
déconvenue pour les enquêteurs à
l'époque du crime fegrez n'habitait plus
à Sucy-en-Brie
votre épouse dont vous êtes séparés a
expliqué que vous n'habitiez plus chez
elle à partir du mois d'avril 2005 je
n'ai plus du tout habité à Sucy-en-Brie
je suis allé vivre chez ma nouvelle
compagne à Colombes
Frédéric Feugrais est donc lavé de tout
soupçon pour les policiers l'enquête
recommence à zéro
[Musique]
48 heures après la mort de Christophe
belle l'enquête va faire un bon
spectaculaire
les policiers apprennent qu'en réalité
Christophe n'est pas le seul
propriétaire de son commerce il a un
associé un certain Xavier Philippe
interrogé par la brigade criminelle
l'homme révèle que la victime lui a
laissé un message sur son répondeur
téléphonique quelques minutes seulement
avant d'être assassiné
le message est enregistré à 2h56 la nuit
de sa mort sur ce message Christophe
belle ne semble pas du tout inquiet sa
voix est tout à fait normale
bon bah à tout de suite je suis là dans
10 15 minutes salut
cette nuit-là Christophe a donc appelé
son associé juste avant de prendre la
route de Sucy-en-Brie tout semble donc
indiqué qu'il avait rendez-vous avec lui
aux yeux des enquêteurs Xavier Philippe
devient donc le suspect numéro 1
interrogé sur ce point voici ce que
l'homme répond
aviez-vous rendez-vous avec Christophe
Bell ce matin-là je n'avais pas
rendez-vous j'ai été très surpris du
contenu du message je ne l'ai pas
compris et c'est pour ça que je les
conservé j'aurais très bien pu l'effacer
vous avez Philippe prends connaissance
de ce message on le sait par la
téléphonie entre 6h40 et 6h45
après la nuit des faits on parle
immédiatement à sa compagne ils en tiens
j'ai un message bizarre de Christophe
que je comprends pas à partir du moment
où il arrive à la boulangerie il fait
écouter ce message à plusieurs des
salariés parce qu'ils ne le comprend
tellement pas qui leur demande de lui
confirmer que c'est bien Christophe pour
convaincre les enquêteurs de son
innocence Xavier Philippe leur
présentent un alibi la nuit du meurtre
il dormait tranquillement chez lui et
d'ailleurs sa compagne peut en témoigner
il est impossible que votre compagnon
soit sorti cette nuit là sans que vous
en ayez connaissance
compte tenu de la disposition des lieux
cela me paraît très difficile voire
impossible
Xavier Philippe a un alibi puisque la
nuit du drame c'est sa femme son alibi
il dit qu'il dormait alors il y a une
particularité il habite dans un duplex
rue Lafayette et en plus il dort dans
une mezzanine et il dort côté mur ce qui
veut dire que pour sortir discrètement
du lit en plus mes amis en bois ça fait
toujours du bruit ça craque quand ça
bouge etc pour sortir du lit non
seulement il faudrait qu'il la fasse pas
bouger mais en plus qui passe par-dessus
son épouse pour redescendre l'escalier
il y a du parquet ça craque etc
seulement ces explications ne vont pas
totalement convaincre les enquêteurs car
la femme de Xavier Philippe pourrait
très bien couvrir son mari en laissant
croire qu'il n'a pas quitté le lit
conjugal
va donc se focaliser sur l'associer du
pâtissier assassiné
Xavier philippe est un homme de 49 ans
sympathique avenant et surtout beau
parleur un homme qui a plutôt bien
réussi dans les affaires
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un de généreux
qui paye facilement de sa personne et de
son porte-monnaie pour aider les gens
quelqu'un de très travailleur ça c'est
quelque chose c'est une caractéristique
de ce garçon il a commencé à travailler
très tôt et il n'a jamais arrêté Xavier
Philippe ça touche à tout il a été
vendeur de voiture il était
professeur de karaté il est passionné
des armes
il a vendu de la fourrure pour Aude la
fille de Xavier son père était un
travailleur certes mais c'est avant tout
un homme assoiffé d'argent
il aime vraiment l'argent il en a besoin
pour vivre besoin je pense pas qu'il
pourrait vivre sans argent c'est
impossible on a besoin
c'est une obsession même si il a l'air
de bien vivre il faut toujours qu'il la
masque la masse cet argent et il
travaillerait mais c'est un mordu du
travail il pourrait travailler jour et
nuit sans même dormir pour pour avoir
cet argent au début des années 90 Xavier
Philippe est l'un des propriétaires du
Banana Café un bar branché de la
capitale fréquenté par la communauté gay
il organise régulièrement dans son
établissement des fêtes qui attirent le
Tout-Paris à cette époque il est à la
recherche d'un pâtissier pour créer des
gâteaux d'anniversaire spectaculaires et
il en parle à l'une de ses connaissances
Nathalie belle
Philippe nous nous
raconter ces soirées exceptionnelles
avec la demande des artistes pour des
gâteaux exceptionnels
or justement Christophe le frère de
Nathalie belle et pâtissier
donc on a tout de suite pensé que
Christophe pouvait être à l'origine de
la fabrication de ces gâteaux là n'a
proposé à mon frère qui avait d'aller
rencontrer Xavier Philippe aubana café
de notre part les deux hommes se
rencontrent et l'affaire est conclue
Christophe belle devient le pâtissier
attitré du Banana Café pour lui c'est un
rêve qui se réalise et petit à petit ce
type a pris une importance par son
savoir-faire c'était le il émerveillait
les fêtes parisiennes il avait un espèce
de don il faisait les pièces montées qui
étaient des véritables sculptures
il avait un réel talent un réel don
c'était à la fois joli et bon ça lui a
permis d'exploiter son art et de faire
des gâteaux exceptionnels et vraiment
sur un thème qui était toujours choisi
en fonction du thème de la soirée
Christophe belle et Xavier Philippe
s'entendent si bien qu'en 1998 les deux
hommes décident de monter une affaire
ensemble
c'est dans la recherche d'une pâtisserie
avec une boulangerie et une boutique
pour pouvoir cette fois-ci vendre à une
clientèle de passage il nous manque bien
sûr les finances
Xavier lui de son côté est aussi à la
recherche de réouvrir une nouvelle
entreprise et il décide de s'associer
tous les deux donc il y en a un qui
avait un savoir-faire la pâtisserie et
l'autre qui avait des fonds
donc ils se sont ils se sont trouvés et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont créé l'avion
d'hélice Christophe belle est un homme
heureux il est maintenant propriétaire
d'une pâtisserie dans le Marais un
quartier aussi branché que touristique
situé en plein cœur de Paris
son association avec Xavier Philippe est
une parfaite réussite
[Musique]
vraiment ils étaient amis d'ailleurs il
venait en vacances on les avait vu en
vacances à Noirmoutier ils étaient
passés ils sont tombés vraiment très
bien tous les deux moi j'ai jamais vu de
mauvaises enfants jamais pendant 5 ans
le succès de la pâtisserie ne se dément
pas jusqu'à ce que Christophe belle
découvre des anomalies dans la
comptabilité de son commerce
Christophe s'est aperçu en fait que la
production augmentait et Xavier lui a
fait part que le chiffre d'affaires
baissait donc là il s'est dit il y a un
souci
il n'est pas normal qu'en vendant deux
fois plus on est deux fois moins
d'argent dans la caisse Christophe
travaille beaucoup il est présent la
pâtisserie 12 heures par jour mais
malgré le succès de son commerce son
train de vie reste toujours aussi
modeste contrairement à celui de son
associé
il y en a un qui fout rien c'est Xavier
et Philippe
il a un appartement dont il est
propriétaire en duplex rue Lafayette
c'est pas rien trois voitures dont un
cabriolet une jeep etc il prend des il
pilotes des hélicoptères il passe ses
vacances à Las Vegas il mène un train de
vie
de milliardaires et on a le pauvre
bougre de de Christophe belle qui est la
la main ouvrière c'est celui qui fait la
fortune de l'entreprise qui avait du mal
à boucler ses fins de moi Christophe
belle a fait confiance pendant longtemps
très longtemps trop longtemps à Xavier
Philippe et puis un jour il a eu des
doutes il a eu des doutes qu'il a
d'ailleurs exprimé modestement
simplement sans agressivité à quelques
membres du personnel à sa concubine à sa
famille en disant je ne comprends pas
manifestement il y a de l'argent qui
part Christophe belle ne fait plus
confiance à Xavier Philippe il est
persuadé que son associé vole dans la
caisse
donc il a demandé des comptes je crois à
Xavier Philippe
j'ai appris de par les employés qu'il y
avait eu une petite dispute entre eux et
j'ai aussi également appris de la part
d'une vendeuse que Christophe avait
demandé à comptabiliser les gâteaux qui
avait été vendu de la journée afin de
faire une estimation du chiffre
d'affaires de la journée et là il s'est
aperçu évidemment il avait il avait il y
avait un trou il y avait un trou il y
avait des gros trous dans la caisse
les dernières semaines vraiment qui
précèdent sa mort
il compte se séparer de Xavier Philippe
parce que il s'est aperçu que qu'il lui
volait de l'argent
il compte arrêter l'association qu'ils
ont ensemble
Christophe belle et son associé décide
de mettre en vente la boulangerie très
vite grâce au bouche à oreille un
acheteur se présente seulement les deux
associés exigent qu'une partie de la
vente soit versée en liquide la boutique
à l'aide vendue 460 000 euros
officiellement l'acheteur
allait leur verser 100000 euros de
soutable pour les enquêteurs ces
informations sont capitales elle
signifie que Xavier Philippe est la
personne à qui la mort de Christophe
belle profitait le plus car les 100.000
euros versés en liquide revenait
intégralement dans sa poche
et ce n'est pas tout
Christophe mort et Christophe vivant
les remboursements bancaires au sein de
la boutique n'était plus les mêmes la
boutique était vendue le prêt remboursé
en effet avec la disparition du
pâtissier les dettes des associés
s'annulaient puisque les deux hommes
avaient souscrit une assurance décès
au total la mort de Christophe belle
pouvait rapporter près de 500 000 euros
à son associé les proches de Christophe
belle commencent alors à se dire que
Xavier Philippe serait un homme
machiavélique qui aurait voulu tirer au
maximum profit du décès
juin 2005 nous sommes au domicile de
Christophe belle à Courbevoie cela fait
un mois que son compagnon a été
assassiné et Sandrine reçoit une visite
surprenante celle de Xavier Philippe
l'homme d'affaires est venu lui parler
de l'assurance vie de Christophe et
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle qui
l'annonce à sa veuve et il me dit écoute
il y a un souci c'est que l'assurance
vie n'est pas à ton nom mais à mon nom
donc là je ne comprends pas trop je lui
dis écoute Xavier c'est impossible que
cette assurance vie soit à ton nom il
est clair Christophe m'a dit à plusieurs
reprises qu'en cas de problème
l'assurance était à mon nom
et je lui dis dans le pire des cas il
n'aurait certainement pas pris cette
assurance en ton nom il aurait pris au
nom de sa mère ou au nom de mes enfants
mais certainement pas à ton nom
il me dit écoute je comprends pas bien
non plus ne t'inquiète pas on s'arrange
et là sandrine a commencé à avoir des
suspicions énormes et évidemment
moi également puisque j'étais au courant
de ce contrat d'assurance vie le
bénéficiaire de cette assurance vie
aurait dû toucher aux alentours de 80 à
120.000 euros nous nous sommes procurés
le contrat d'assurance vie de Christophe
belle et en effet à la ligne
bénéficiaire c'est le nom de Xavier
Philippe qui apparaît et non celui de la
compagne du pâtissier
[Musique]
pour Sandrine cette nouvelle est
incroyable pourquoi Christophe belle
a-t-il désigné son associé comme
bénéficiaire de son assurance vie plutôt
qu'elle et elle soupçonne un faux
seulement une expertise graphologique va
totalement écarter cette possibilité
à partir du moment où l'expertise
graphologique est revenue et où l'expert
a dit de façon absolument catégorique
non seulement c'est la main de
Christophe belle mais il y a pas de
retenue il y a pas de réserve parfois
les gens qui hésitent qui écrivent sous
la menace sous la dictée on trouve des
signes dans l'écriture rien bon écriture
naturelle de Christophe donc ce serait
une manipulation comment on sait pas
dans quelles conditions on ne sait pas
est-ce que crie manipulation
erreur jusqu'à ce jour personne ne sait
pourquoi Christophe a désigné son
associé comme bénéficiaire de son
assurance vie
mais cette affaire conforte les
policiers dans leur convictions pour
Xavier Philippe et le suspect idéal seul
problème il ne dispose d'aucune preuve
matérielle alors les hommes du quai des
Orfèvres décident de se pencher en
détail sur son passé et ils vont
découvrir que Xavier Philippe est loin
d'être inconnu des services de police
ces premiers écarts datent de 1982 et à
l'époque il ne vit pas à Paris
août 1982 à Orléans Xavier Philippe a
une vingtaine d'années il ne s'est pas
encore lancé dans les affaires mais son
frère jumeau-bertrand est déjà
propriétaire d'une discothèque le
quiproquo et c'est ici qu'un soir Xavier
va pour la première fois faire preuve
d'une violence surprenante
c'est une scène où il y a un groupe de
voyous qui attaque la boîte de nuit de
leur frère Xavier arrive sur ces
entrefaits par malheur il a une arme
dans sa voiture et bêtement il va en
faire usage contre ce groupe
effectivement va crever l'oeil de l'un
des malfaiteurs Xavier Philippe est
reconnu coupable de violences avec armes
il est condamné à trois mois de prison
ferme
mais à peine libérer Xavier va de
nouveau s'attirer de graves ennuis il va
tenter de mettre le feu à la discothèque
de son frère et il a ce geste fou
d'aller mettre le feu alors il explique
à cet endroit qui qui est le symbole de
cette souffrance qu'il a de la prison de
l'injustice et il veut mourir avec alors
ça c'est difficile de le contester
puisqu'effectivement si son père n'était
pas venu le chercher dans le brasier il
serait mort cette tentative d'incendie
cache visiblement autre chose Xavier
Philippe serait en réalité maladivement
jaloux de la réussite de son frère
depuis des années il cherche à égaler sa
réussite sans jamais y parvenir
chaque fois qu'ils ouvrent un
établissement Xavier Philippe va en
ouvrir un
qui ressemble beaucoup dans les mois ou
les années qui suivent pour essayer de
faire la même chose on parlera de
commerce de fourrure on parlera
d’établissement de nuit de barre à
chaque fois Xavier Philippe et derrière
a essayé de faire la même chose à singer
mais avec moins de talent manifestement
son frère et je pense qu'il est dans un
rapport de jalousie terrible pour avoir
tenté de mettre le feu à la discothèque
de son frère Xavier Philippe est à
nouveau condamné par la justice il est
Cope d'une peine de 18 mois de prison
ferme il sera libéré en février 1984
mais très vite il va refaire parler de
lui
nous sommes en août 1986 une péniche
restaurant déborde Loire à Orléans et
soufflé par une explosion rapidement au
soupçonne un incendie criminel
commandité par le propriétaire or cette
péniche appartient à la mère de Xavier
Philippe et lui-même en est le gérant ce
qu'on appelle un habituellement
l'escroquerie à l'assurance c'est à dire
l'idée c'est d'aller simuler un cynisme
pour pouvoir être indemnisé et d'après
ce que je sais cet établissement pouvait
à l'époque connaître un certain nombre
de difficultés était parfaitement assuré
entre le propriétaire des murs et le
propriétaire du fonds de commerce et que
économiquement cette opération que l'on
pourrait imaginer catastrophique pour
Xavier Philippe et sa mère a été plutôt
une opération économiquement tout à fait
valable l'enquête pour incendie
volontaire n'aboutit pas faute de preuve
Xavier Philippe et relaxé mais le
parcours de l'homme d'affaires recèle
encore bien des mystères non élucidés
[Musique]
alors que les hommes du quai des
Orfèvres continuent de fouiller dans le
passé de Xavier Philippe ils vont
rencontrer l'une de ses anciennes
compagnes Céline et celle-ci va alors
révéler un secret qu'elle gardait pour
elle depuis 17 ans
Orléans 17 novembre 1988 on signale la
disparition d'un homme Pascal Leroy il
dirige une petite société de transport
et depuis peu il a un associé Xavier
Philippe à l'époque faute d'indice
l'affaire est classée la disparition de
Pascal Leroy reste inexpliquée du moins
jusqu'à l'audition de l'ex-compagne de
Xavier Philippe elle va leur faire une
confidence pendant son audition
à savoir que un soir une nuit de 1988
son mari était rentré tard dans la nuit
et
[Musique]
dans un état d'excitation important et
lui aurait confié avoir liquidé son
associé qui s'appelait Pascal Leroy ma
mère au départ pensait un accident la
route
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé raconte-moi et
du coup mais j'ai buté Pascal Europe
parce que j'avais peur d'aller en prison
alors donc là bon ma mère lui aurait dit
bon bah écoute calme-toi parce qu'il
paraît qu'il était vraiment dans un état
vraiment dans l'état second et elle a eu
peur elle a vraiment eu peur de lui et
du coup de calme-toi bon elle a commencé
à discuter avec lui il veut et puis dès
qu'elle lui a dit on va on va aller
ensemble au commissariat là tout de
suite il s'est énervé je pourrais pas
vous dire exactement les propos qui lui
a dit mais c'était de l'énervement de la
menace alors donc maman ma mère a eu
très peur il est reparti dans la nuit
Céline prendra peur en voyant son
compagnon Xavier Philippe la menacé elle
décide de rompre et d'oublier cette
histoire de meurtre à tout jamais mais
lorsqu'elle apprend la mort de
Christophe belle et l'arrestation de son
ancien mari Céline soulage sa conscience
si maman n'a rien dit pendant toutes ces
années c'est parce qu'elle avait peur
elle avait peur de la réaction de Xavier
et elle a commencé à en parler quand
vous aviez était incarcéré parce qu'elle
savait qu'à ce moment vous ne pouvez
plus rien faire il ne pouvait pas
l'atteindre et elle regrette de ne pas
avoir pu parler avant ok des Orfèvres le
puzzle se met en place les policiers se
disent bon là ça commence à faire
beaucoup 88 un premier associé qui
disparaît
là Christophe belle est associé
et il est retrouvé assassiné donc ça
fait au moins déjà deux associés qui
sont morts et ce qui va vraiment
bétonner la conviction policière ou
judiciaire c'est l'affaire Tony Gomez
printemps 1998 nous sommes au Banana
Café à cette époque Christophe belle
n'est pas encore le pâtissier de
l'établissement le bar est dirigé par un
certain Tony Gomez l'ami des stars une
figure des nuits parisiennes
[Applaudissements]
son associé n'est autre que Xavier
Philippe mais à cette époque les
relations entre les deux hommes ne sont
pas au beau fixe Tony Gomez supporte de
moins en moins le comportement
autoritaire de son collaborateur
il explique que en réalité ils se sont
opposés dans le cadre de leurs affaires
parce que parce qu'il avait le sentiment
de travailler beaucoup de travailler
énormément mais que les cordons de la
bourse étaient tenus ils s'étaient fait
voler finalement son commerce parc
Xavier Philippe et c'est dans ce climat
tendu que le 28 avril 1998 Tony Gomez va
vivre un événement qui aurait pu
s'avérer dramatique
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le quartier du Marais
au domicile de Tony Gomez ce soir là le
patron du Banana Café est sorti dans
l'appartement Grégory son compagnon est
seul le jeune homme ne peut pas se
douter qu'un individu s'est introduit
dans le duplex
le compagnon de Tony Gomez entendu bruit
dans l'appartement il va voir ça duplex
il va voir ce qui se passe
et là il est face à face avec un homme
cagoulé en noir qui lui tire dessus
et le type disparaît
seulement blessé Grégory alerte
immédiatement la police le quartier est
bouclé les policiers se lancent à la
recherche de l'homme en fuite un homme
qu'ils vont très vite retrouver
ce type qui s'appelle samicia est arrêté
dans un café en possession de l'arme
qu'il avait utilisé quelques instants
auparavant le tireur Alain samicia à 40
ans et il a déjà passé un séjour en
prison il y a quelques années lors de
son interrogatoire il garde le silence
alors la police va éplucher ses relevés
téléphoniques et découvrir que l'homme a
eu de nombreuses conversations avec
Xavier Philippe quelques jours seulement
avant l'agression mieux encore les deux
hommes se connaîtraient depuis très
longtemps
on découvre également qu'en 1982 les
deux hommes c'est à dire samicia celui
qui est qui a tiré au domicile de Tony
Gomez et Xavier Philippe ont été
incarcérés pendant au moins un mois dans
la même prison à Orléans alors Xavier
Philippe a-t-il commandité l'agression
au domicile de Tony Gomez voulait-il
effrayer son associé pire voulait-il le
tuer pour en tirer profit
si Tony Gomez décédait Xavier Philippe
avec sa mère
héritait du Banana Café Xavier Philippe
est mis en examen pour complicité de
tentatives d'assassinat l'affaire n'a
toujours pas été jugée et l'homme est
donc toujours présumé innocent
[Musique]
en revanche pour le meurtre de
Christophe belle les enquêteurs n'ont
pas encore réuni suffisamment de preuves
pour leur envoyer devant une cour
d'assises mais cela ne va pas tarder
29 novembre 2005 domicile de Xavier
Philippe 10e arrondissement de Paris
les policiers perquisitionnent chez le
suspense et ils vont faire une
découverte incroyable l'homme possède
chez lui un véritable arsenal il avait
une
d'armes dans son appartement à Paris
donc il y en avait donc soufflé il y en
avait dans des petites tables basses en
verre donc transparent il avait accroché
sur les murs il y avait des sabres il y
a pas forcément des armes de la gare
39-45 il va aussi des masques il y avait
des grenades il y avait toutes sortes
d'armes
là on est plus dans la collection simple
on est en présence d'un arsenal enfin
c'est plus de la collection vous voyez
je dirais
la collectionneur du dimanche mais si
Xavier Philippe est passionné d'armes
cela ne fait pas de lui pour autant un
meurtrier
enfin on ne trouve pas l'arme de guerre
on ne trouve pas d'armes interdite je
crois que Marcille il y a effectivement
quelques armes qui auraient nécessité
déclaration
il y a pas eu de procédure incident donc
tout ça n'était pas tout ça n'était pas
bien tout ça n'était pas bien grave donc
c'est vrai qu'il a la passion des armes
c'est vrai qu'il détient des armes d'un
autre côté encore une fois faut le
relativiser parce que vous avez des
collectionneurs de guerre ou d'armes
actuelles on est loin de ça on est très
loin de ça avec lui et en effet la
police ne trouvera pas le revolver 6 35
qui a été utilisé six mois plus tôt pour
tuer Christophe belle
ok des Orfèvres un interrogatoire de
plusieurs heures commence pour Xavier
fini
confronté aux différents éléments de
l'enquête l'homme d'affaires ni toujours
être le meurtrier du pâtissier
les heures passent la tension monte la
fatigue aussi
jusqu'à ce que le suspect commettent un
faux pas lorsqu'il est interrogé à
propos de la mort de Christophe Bell
c'est lorsqu'il est entendu et là il est
suspect numéro un dans le cadre de
l'enquête
[Musique]
il est face aux policiers et un moment
dans un moment d'énervement il va dire
aux policiers alors qu'ils sont face à
face il va lui dire c'est pas moi qui ai
mis trois balles dans la tête de
Christophe belle et là le policier se
dit c'est bon je le tiens
personne n'a jamais parlé des trois
balles personne connaissait l'existence
des trois balles Christophe belle a
effectivement été abattu de trois balles
mais depuis le début de l'enquête la
brigade criminelle dissimule
volontairement cette information
aucun article de presse aucune personne
ne savait que mon frère était tué de
trois mâles dans la tête parce que en
plus les premières constatations
policières faisaient état de deux balles
pour moi Christophe avait été assassiné
de deux balles la police le jour du 17
mai m'a dit on a retrouvé votre
compagnon assassiné de deux balles dans
le bois du pipe à celui-ci en Brie alors
si Xavier Philippe est au courant pour
les trois balles pour les enquêteurs
cela signifie forcément qu'il est le
meurtrier de Christophe belle et à
partir de là je dirais pas que ses aveux
sont signés mais en tout cas
la certitude policière
est installée à cet instant là
voici donc ce qui se serait passé dans
la nuit du 17 mai 2005 peu avant trois
heures du matin Christophe belle quitte
son domicile
vers 3h30 les deux hommes se retrouvent
sur le parking de la forêt du Pipe
Xavier Philippe entraîne son associé
dans le bois au bout d'une centaine de
mètres les deux hommes s'arrêtent pour
discuter Christophe et serein il n'a
aucune raison de se méfier
profitant d'un moment où il se retourne
pour allumer une cigarette Xavier
Philippe sort son arme
pour mener les enquêteurs sur une fausse
piste Xavier Philippe dépose ensuite un
peu de cocaïne à proximité du corps puis
il quitte le bois mais ce que Xavier
ignore à cet instant c'est que quelques
minutes plus tôt en partant de chez lui
Christophe belle lui a laissé un message
téléphonique message qui sera la
principale pièce à charge du procès qui
approche
bon bah à tout de suite je suis là dans
10 15 minutes salut
[Musique]
c'est tout ou rien dans ce dossier la
cour d'assise du Val-de-Marne se donne
15 jours pour trancher Xavier Philippe
la cinquantaine élégante est-il ou non
un tueur en série d'associés le
lendemain des faits il est venu chez moi
ma série dans ses bras serrée mes
enfants dans ses bras et je pense que
je ne sais pas comment il doit être à
l'heure actuelle mais j'espère qu'il a
pas la conscience tranquille il est
tellement évident d'argent il volera de
nouveau et il tuera de nouveau c'est
évident ça fait partie de son processus
dès le début des audiences fidèle à sa
ligne de conduite Xavier Philippe
clament son innocence
je pense que Xavier Philippe est très
très forte psychologiquement peut-être
par question de fierté
n'avouera jamais moi je suis convaincue
que on n'aura jamais d'aveu de sa part
mais je suis aussi convaincue qu'il est
coupable
l'accusation n'aura aucune peine à
démontrer que Xavier Philippe escroquet
son associé plusieurs témoins viennent à
la barre le confirmer
on a des témoins les vendeuses de la
boutique les pâtissiers qui
travaillaient
qui ont témoigné disant que Xavier
Philippe prenait de l'argent dans la
caisse j'ai vu Xavier prendre l'argent
de la caisse et le mettre dans sa poche
oui tout à fait et oui quand j'ai
demandé ça il me disait que parce que
j'irai c'est lui qui gérait l'argent
mais l'élément le plus accablant c'est
le message laissé par la victime le soir
de sa mort à Xavier Philippe un message
qui selon l'accusation pauvre sans aucun
doute que les deux hommes avaient
rendez-vous le soir du crime je pense
que quand vous avez Philippe a entendu
le matin
le message de mon frère
il a dû se trouver dans une situation
extrêmement difficile parce que ça
c'était pas prévu dans l'organisation du
crime on a
frôlé pour reprendre certains termes le
crime parfait c'est à dire que s'il n'y
avait pas eu cet appel on aurait au jour
d'aujourd'hui à rien on peut considérer
que Christophe sans même le savoir à
désigner son assassin même l'avocat de
Xavier Philippe maître Sarda est obligé
de reconnaître que ce message pèse très
lourdement contre son client
alors ce message est évidemment une
charge c'est indéniable c'est la charge
de ce dossier il est tout à fait normal
que les policiers aient suspectés que
vous avez Philippe à partir du moment où
il se connaissances de ce message
c'est-à-dire dès le lendemain des faits
évidemment c'est un message dont
l'interprétation naturelle logique c'est
qu'ils ont rendez-vous c'est indéniable
alors vous avez Philippe a toujours
affirmé qu'il n'avait pas rendez-vous
pour l'accusé le message serait en fait
une erreur et c'est à quelqu'un d'autre
que Christophe belle pensait téléphoner
mais cet argument est contré
immédiatement par la participation
civile
on a retrouvé le téléphone portable de
Christophe Berl il a été vérifié et plus
cher analysé et dans son répertoire il y
a trois numéros pour joindre Xavier
Philippe son associé
perso donc son domicile Xavier
portable et Xavier Marcilly qui est son
sa résidence secondaire donc le portable
se trouve entre son domicile et sa
résidence au secondaire donc même si
c'est trompé d'une ligne ou l'autre il
retombera sur Xavier dernier argument de
la défense Xavier Philippe ne peut pas
être le meurtrier puisque comme il le
répète il a un alibi sa compagne
Nathalie l'affirme il a passé la nuit
près d'elle l'avocat de l'homme
d'affaires va même aller jusqu'à
projeter devant la course cette vidéo
qu'il a tourné lui-même dans
l'appartement de son client
il entend y démontrer que si Xavier
Philippe s'était levé cette nuit là il
n'aurait pas pu éviter de faire du bruit
et donc de réveiller sa femme
[Musique]
pour se lever à konito c'est extrêmement
difficile et c'est évidemment exactement
la même chose pour le chemin inverse
donc nathalie est très sereine pour dire
que Xavier Philippe non cette nuit-là ne
sait pas levé ne s'est pas absenté
pendant au moins deux heures
parce que si on fait le calcul des temps
de trajet du temps du meurtre sur place
et du retour on est à au moins deux
heures
et n'est pas revenu dans ce lit sans que
ni le chien ni notre fils ni moi nous
aurions compte
mais cette vidéo pour le moins
surprenante ne convainc personne et du
côté de l'accusation fait remarquer
qu'il est bien difficile de se fier aux
témoignage de l'épouse de Xavier car
elle est forcément partiale
[Musique]
sa compagne s'accompagne affirme qu'il
était là toute la nuit près d'elle mais
on peut tout imaginer enfin je veux dire
on peut imaginer que Xavier dormi dans
une pièce à côté on peut imaginer que
Xavier est donné à somnifère à sa
compagne on peut imaginer que
qu'elle le couvre
au bout de quelques jours de procès la
défense de Xavier Philippe semble bien
fragilisée l'homme avait un mobile son
alibi est bien mince et son passé
judiciaire en fait un coupable idéal
l'accusation va lui donner le coup de
grâce
[Musique]
souvenez-vous au début de l'enquête les
policiers ont soupçonné un autre
pâtissier avec lequel Christophe belle
avait des ennuis Frédéric Feugrais
l'accusation affirme désormais que cette
rivalité faisait partie du plan de
Xavier Philippe cela lui aurait permis
de manipuler sa victime et de tromper la
police
on peut parler d'une forme de
préparation pour désigner un coupable
dans les semaines et moi qui ont précédé
la mort de Christophe belle il a
effectivement été victime d'un certain
nombre de saccage de sa moto les pneus
étaient crevés le fond de commerce enfin
la pâtisserie a été a été visitée
cambriolé et à l'époque on essayait en
tout cas Xavier Philippe essayait de
faire porter le la responsabilité de ces
de ces malversations au fameux Feugrais
ce serait donc qu'en proposant à
Christophe belle d'aller régler ce
différent avec Feugrais qui habite à
Sucy-en-Brie que Xavier Philippe aurait
réussi à attirer sa victime aussi loin
de chez lui
l'assassin faisait d'une pierre deux
coups puisque cela lui permettait
également de détourner l'attention vers
un faux coupable
on peut imaginer parce que c'est un type
extrêmement intelligent Xavier Philippe
qu'il avait déjà préparé
la façon de désigner un coupable et ça
aurait pu fonctionner parce que s'il
fait grève et dormi tout seul à
Sucy-en-Brie il serait peut-être en
prison alors qu'il est
après 15 jours de procès et malgré
l'absence de preuve matérielles le jury
à l'unanimité condamne Xavier Philippe à
30 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
avoir assassiné son associé Christophe
belle
[Musique]
le fait que les gens le juraient
d'assisent que la Cour soit convaincue
de sa culpabilité telle que nous le
l'étions
m'a conforté dans mon idée m'a permis de
d'être assuré que c'était lui voilà
d'autres personnes ça que c'était lui et
non condamné la sentence sera confirmée
en appel en 2010
[Musique]